fire today yeah it's a great day great
day and a great announcement today and
thank you all for joining us joining us
here today it's a wonderful day for a
number of you for all of us and for
Carnegie Mellon University for sure and
I have a start-up role excuse me that I
have a number of people who important
people to introduce we've got a large
crowd here today we're very pleased
about us so let me start right away and
by welcoming Farnum Joe honey and Farnum
did you please stay
[Applause]
you'd be the tenth president of Carnegie
Mellon University I'm welcome tres thank
you for being here if you could please
stand daughter Sara Thomas the sons
Thomas and Dan are joining us in my
webcast today welcome to them good to
have you with us today now as you know
the the search process is quite a
process as we call it but I want to
really thank Todd Johnson and gene van
breezin and all the members of the
presidential search committee who have
joined us today please stand up and be
recognized
[Applause]
jeana's you turn around you saw all
those people standing in the back you
you know maybe they were on the
committee too as well but the feedback
we got about 400 was it was terrific
these colleagues have put in long hours
and poured their heart and soul than
defining CMU's next president we're very
grateful for their service I would like
to also recognize the member of the
Board of Trustee boards for the board of
trustees who've joined us today if they
could please stand and be recognized
[Applause]
I don't how many times you're gonna have
to stand here today thank you
mayor Peduto is represented today by
Valerie McDonald Roberts the mayor's
chief kerbin affairs officer Valerie
Hershey and we're also joined and by
Pittsburgh's newest City Councilwoman
Erica Strassburger Erica can you please
stay I would like to recognize the
University leadership council composed
of our Dean's Vice Presidents and vice
provost if they could please stand to be
recognized and now join me in welcoming
student government leaders who has
joined us today
Travis Carlos neo Chowdhury pookie
module mate read Joshi Gabriella ketch
Hana nori would you please stand to be
recognized thank you
[Applause]
they also have the president of our
Alumni Association Board Debbie you
Debbie would you still believe Stan and
last but not least would you join me in
welcoming the chair of CMU staff counsel
Tim Leonard Tim please stand any
presidential appointment has the power
to change the course and trajectory of
the University for trustees the
selection of this individual and
oversight of the president is far and
away our most important role but I would
venture to say that Carnegie Mellon's
lively history no presidency has been
more important than the one we are about
to enter and really for the best reasons
you've heard me say many times is this
is an extraordinary time for Carnegie
Mellon University in our fast
accelerating era of technological
process progress disruption the world
needs the best scientists technologists
and researchers to lead the way it also
needs the entrepreneurs and business
people who bring these technologies to
market and the policymakers ethicists
economists psychologists educators and
artists who ensure that all of this
change ultimately benefits mankind CMU
has leaders in each of these disciplines
more importantly it has a distinct
culture that puts those scholars
teachers researchers and performers
together and encourages them to
collaborate on real work real-world
projects that make concrete benefits for
people and even as they make their
breakthroughs that are changing the
world around us they are also training
the next generation of bold
collaborative creative leaders and
thinkers doers and makers to take
advantage of all that CMU needs the
right leader and Farnam Jehan ian
possesses a rare set of qualities and
experiences that make him exactly the
right leader for this university in this
extraordinary moment of time Farnum is a
computer
scientist whose scholarship has advanced
this field and an entrepreneur who knows
firsthand how to bring knowledge to
market he served as a policymaker
working tirelessly to make sure
technology enhances our society and in
particular ensuring that its benefits
are available to women underrepresented
minorities and people from all walks of
life he's an educator with a love of the
Arts and a CMU parent who understands
and deeply cares about the student
experience and in the breadth of his
experience the boldness of his vision
and the pragmatic and progres pragmatic
creativity that marks his leadership
Farnum embodies the qualities that make
this university great as we've seen
through his during his time as provost
and interim president dr. johan ian has
led this institution with an
irresistible urgency and a determination
to seize the opportunities at hand
he's enabled the Dean's senior
administrators faculty staff and
students to pursue excellence at every
level of their work and he's facilitated
new levels of collaboration across the
institution an essential step in
securing CMU's place among the world's
greatest universities he's earned the
confidence the enthusiasm the
enthusiastic support of the trustees
CMU's benefactors and more than a
hundred thousand alumni around the world
and I can tell you personally I think
this individual has the vision to take
us to the next level
anyone who knows Farnum knows that he
has the passion to make sure that every
constituency of Carnegie Mellon has
benefited both on and off campus and to
the extent that you know Farnum you know
that his heart is in the work partum
congratulations
[Applause]
this time I'd like to welcome to the
stage gene ran Brees and co-chair the
presidential search committee and chair
of the Faculty Senate
[Applause]
thank you Jim it's my great pleasure to
represent the Presidential Search
Committee this afternoon I want to thank
chairman Jim Rohr and the entire board
of trustees for their endorsement of our
work and their selection of doctor
Farnum Jehan e'en as the next president
of Carnegie Mellon University I would
also like to acknowledge and thank
trustee Todd Johnson who chaired our
search committee leading a terrific
group of faculty and trustees over the
past eight months as we conducted a
comprehensive international search for
the next leader of this great
institution I want to particularly thank
my faculty colleagues on the search
committee for their deep engagement with
our shared task here with me today our
David Kaufer and Mandel dance work todd
prosimian and denis russo Irene Fonseca
sends her regrets and her
congratulations to our new president I
also want to thank the incredibly
supportive staff who worked with the
committee Cathy Light chief of staff and
secretary of the corporation
Karen Cohn assistant secretary of the
corporation
Karen maker assistant to the president
and Mary Jo Dively vice president and
chief counsel Cathy and Karen and Karen
did an amazing amount of work
coordinating all of the moving parts of
an incredibly complex process and Mary
Jo embodied her title by providing wise
counsel throughout I also want to thank
Denis Phase II oh the second of
executive the Senate executive officer
who supports all of my work as Faculty
Senate chair as Jim aptly summarized our
charge to find the next leader of this
institution was the significant
responsibility we dedicated our work to
finding a president who would value our
unique culture of innovation and
collaboration leading us to build on the
potential of this moment in our history
we received input from the community
through town hall meetings and many
comments sent through the web portal we
heard from students staff faculty and
alumni I am truly grateful to all those
members of the Carnegie Mellon community
who took time to send us their thoughts
to recommend candidates and to voice
their opinions on the future of Carnegie
Mellon and the characteristics needed
for its next leader certain leadership
characteristics were mentioned again and
again a visionary leader aligned with
Carnegie Mellon's values collaboration
collegiality and innovation a thought
leader aligned with our strategic vision
a motivated partner for internal and
external stakeholders a high energy
champion of Carnegie Mellon's impact and
recognition and a thoughtful accessible
tireless presence in the life of the
Carnegie Mellon community our students
our staff our faculty in our alumni we
were pleased to find these
characteristics in dr. Farnum Jahan Ian
his combination of vision dedication and
engagement impressed us as much as his
academic credentials and experience his
collaborative leadership style and his
openness to continuous learning about
Carnegie Mellon fit what we heard from
you our community in conclusion I want
to offer my sincere congratulations to
dr. Johan Ian on this well-deserved
appointment he's a well accomplished
computer scientist entrepreneur and has
held several other academic and
government leadership positions known
for his deep engagement with students
and his dedication to improving their
experience on campus dr. johan ian has
already had an enormous impact at CMU
good evening
as one of the top institutions in the
world were really hard-working place
there's no question about that but I
Carnegie Mellon when we talk about work
we mean something a little different
we're actively engaged in work that
matters we're at the forefront of
bringing people together from diverse
backgrounds in science in engineering
humanities public policy business the
arts to address the pressing issues
facing society were positioned like no
other institution to define and manage
the space where technology and human
life intersect and to train the next
generation to solve the problem of
global significance this new era will be
fuelled by ideas by breakthroughs in new
materials and digital technologies and
robotics how do we contribute to this
innovation economy
well it's through the startups have come
out of these universities it's also
creating a entrepreneurial environment
where entrepreneurs and innovators want
to come to Pittsburgh and be here he had
his hands in everything good at Carnegie
Mellon and there is no question that in
the few years that he has been a part of
the Tartan family he has made lasting
impacts to this
institution I'm in awe of this community
and all that it represents the passion
the ingenuity the creativity and the
pride your passion fuels this great
University you are Carnegie Mellon
[Applause]
here who has brought Carnegie Mellon to
this magnificent place that we sit in
today there's one of the great
institutions of the entire world and now
let me let me is take one step into the
future it introduced to you the tenth
president of the University of Carnegie
Mellon University Farnum John
[Applause]
please be seated good afternoon oh I'm
gonna have to try this again okay good
afternoon much better much better thank
you so much for being here today first
I'm sorry that we had to change your
lunch plans on short notice you know I
woke up this morning and one of the
first email messages that I received was
from a faculty colleague who wanted to
know the status of Posner Hall more
specifically when we were planning to
finalize the decision on who moves into
Vaz near Hall after our temporary school
faculty moved to the Tempur quad and
then a few minutes later I got an email
from the same faculty who said ignore my
previous message I guess you're gonna be
a little busy today congratulations Jim
I realized that my honeymoon as new
president of Carnegie Mellon was over by
about 8:05 this morning I want to start
by first of all expressing my profound
gratitude to our chairman Jim roar Jim
thank you for your kind words today and
for your leadership of the Board of
Trustees and for your passion for your
commitment to Carnegie Mellon I'm
personally grateful to you for your
counsel during my time here and also to
have your support and your mentorship
moving forward Jim will you please stand
the three recognized
it's incredibly meaningful to be
standing here with the endorsement of
our committed Board of Trustees I wish
to thank the CMU board for placing their
trust in me to lead this great
university at this extraordinary time I
would also like to express my gratitude
to members of the search committee for
their commitment and service to CMU
special thanks of course to committee
co-chairs the leadership of Todd Johnson
vice chairman of the board of trustees
and of course Jean Van Driessen the
chair of our Faculty Senate once again
please join me in thanking
I also want to take a special moment to
recognize two men who've had an historic
impact on this university and who have
been so generous in offering their wise
counsel to me throughout my time here
Jerry Cohen president emeritus mark kam
the former Provost
it means a great deal to me to have
Jerry and his wife bunny as well as Mark
to be here today thank you for
everything that you have done for
Carnegie Mellon over the years will you
please stand to be recognized once again
I'm also delighted to have our student
leaders with us representing almost
14,000 students across this great
institution including Neil pol Keita
Travis Maitri Gabriella and Hanna thank
you for being such an outstanding
partners and leaders while I'm thanking
students special shout out to a
contingent of students from our Doha and
CMU Africa campuses who are here with us
today in Pittsburgh will you please join
me in recognizing all of its students
that are here with
you know in talking with our students
from our international campuses over the
last three years I've noticed how young
adults look at the world with the same
optimism the same bold aspirations and
the same desire to make an impact no
matter where they come from students
know that the education they receive at
CMU will provide them the opportunity to
achieve their dreams at the end of the
day we're here because of you our
students to all of our CMU students and
alumni who are here with us today or
watching on our livestream thank you for
your energy for your enthusiasm and your
passion that you bring to this
University I'm also humbled by accepting
this responsibilities surrounded by my
outstanding colleagues and friends our
interim provost Laurie weingartz the
deans the executive management team
leaders from across the university our
brilliant faculty and our dedicated
staff thank you for being here and thank
you for all that you do for this
institution
[Applause]
finally to my wife Tris
my wife and my partner thank you for
being by my side today and every day my
daughter Sara who's more than halfway
through her junior year here at Carnegie
Mellon I love you pops thank you for
always letting me embarrass you in front
of your friends
it started in kindergarten and it
continues to date and my son's of course
Daniel and Thomas I know you're watching
from Ann Arbor hi guys
love you
today I'm deeply honored to accept this
appointment as the next president of
this great institution in this
fantastically vibrant city of Pittsburgh
it's a great privilege and a tremendous
responsibility but it is most of all an
absolute thrill to know that I'll be
working side by side with so many of you
not only our faculty students staff
alumni and parents but also our civic
and community leaders leaders from the
foundation community policymakers in
Pittsburgh Harrisburg and Washington DC
our corporate partners from around the
world and our so many supporters
together we will continue to do work
that matters work that benefits people
all around the world we hear a lot about
the headwinds facing higher education
these days and our real beyond public
questions surrounding the value of a
college degree even mistrust for
academia there are deeper issues that we
must confront especially access and
affordability for college education
constrained federal investment in basic
research and higher education intense
competition for recruiting and retaining
outstanding talent as well as societal
challenges that I know weigh heavily on
our young generation including diversity
inclusion and equity mental health
sexual harassment and misconduct free
speech and the urgent need for civil
discourse it would be easy to fall into
hand-wringing and so become so paralyzed
by the mire of problems out there it's
so easy to fall into that trap that we
would miss the enormous opportunities in
front of us
so today I stand here as a true believer
in the power of higher education I'm a
true believer in something the education
pioneer Horace Mann said in 1848 and I
quote education then beyond all other
devices of human origin is the great
equalizer and the balance wheel of the
social machinery let me be clear there's
no question that higher education can
bridge social economic racial and
geographical divides like no other force
I firmly believe that as part of a
profound social contract higher
education has been provided a degree of
autonomy and influence in exchange for
performing two core missions increasing
the base of knowledge for society and
educating the next generation of leaders
in science engineering business
humanities the performing arts and more
I believe because I have seen it
firsthand in my own education which
opened so many doors especially as an
immigrant who came to this country when
I was 16 as a researcher and as an
entrepreneur who has seen the enormous
economic power of a single idea by the
way
a quick story here my first true sense
of what Carnegie Mellon University
students were capable of was through Rob
Mallon a former CMU undergraduate in ECE
who also worked on the mock project in
the early 90s and I recruited him to
University of Michigan for his graduate
studies in 1994
20-some years ago Rob's appearance at
first was a little deceptive
I think our undergraduates can relate to
that
he's a Grateful Dead fan who could seem
a little distracted at times and first
impression but he had this lazer sharp
clarity about the most challenging
problems of our research work his
ability to cut through the confusion
that threatened to swallow his
collaborators Rob later co-founded Arbor
networks with me and has gone to have an
extraordinary successful career in
high-tech friends colleagues that CMU
I'm also a believer in higher education
because I saw in public service where it
became so clear that the ideas and
creations emerging from higher education
serve as a foundation of our success as
a nation driving our economic prosperity
and most of all I'm a believer because I
have seen as someone who has spent a
bulk of his career in higher education
including here at CMU over the last few
years as Provost and as your interim
president I've had the rare opportunity
and the honor to look into every corner
of this amazing institution I've gone to
spend time with Carnegie Mellon artists
for pushing the boundaries of creativity
and the student performers logging long
hours of rehearsal laying the foundation
for their own brilliant success I've
gotten to dive deep with the CMU
scholars and researchers who are pushing
the boundaries of their field and so
often jumping fence all together to work
with colleagues in unexpected places
when researchers interact like this we
multiply our impact and cede new ideas
with the potential to lead to
unanticipated outcomes
I've gotten to spend time in classrooms
across our campus and to watch some of
our most gifted educators employing
every tool at their disposal from
technology enhanced learning to plain
old human inspiration to teach a new
generation of leaders to imagine broadly
think critically and work
collaboratively and finally I've gotten
to work closely with our Provost Dean's
department heads vice presidents and
extraordinary staff across this
University who are stretching themselves
every day to support the research and
education at the heart of our endeavor
as Jim Rohr pointed out this is truly an
extraordinary time for this institution
today we find ourselves in the midst of
a global transformation catalyzed by a
rapid acceleration in the scope scale
and ubiquity of digital technologies now
more than any other time in our history
Carnegie Mellon is uniquely positioned
to meet the needs of this century based
on our historic strengths in
foundational research CMU offers
uncommon excellence in computation data
and engineering touching almost every
part of our lives next-generation
advanced manufacturing cybersecurity
decision science neuroscience cognitive
science robotics artificial intelligence
that's CMU so is cleaning up at the
Tonys
and a Putnam competition leading in
transition design becoming the first
degree-granting drama institution in the
United States and so much more
but what truly defines us as an
institution is not any one school one
discipline or an award deep in our DNA
we're about problem-solving and fearless
creativity at the edges and
intersections of traditional boundaries
the story of this century will depend on
things we do best exploration at the
Nexus of technology and society
data-driven analytics entrepreneurial
thinking and new forms of creative
expressions and so much more you know
ever ever since I joined CMU I've drawn
inspiration from this incredible
community whether it was visiting
students and faculty in their classrooms
and laboratories enjoying artistics
artistic and dramatic performances
engaging with alumni all over the world
watching and cheering our student
athletes and yes even helping our Dean's
get into the dunk tank during Carnival
I am truly in awe of all of you all that
you have to offer and your dedication to
making the world smarter safer more
equitable and more inspiring no one
brings more passion creativity and Prive
to their work that our outstanding
community I am looking forward to
hearing your dreams for shaping the
world and the future of this great
institution and working with you to make
them possible once again to our Board of
Trustees Chairman Rohr and the entire
university community thank you now let's
get to work
thank you very much
[Applause]